Oh wait, wait. You're letting
listening to radio lab radio from W N y.
S t.
All right. Hello? Hello? Hello?
Hello? Hello? Hello. I can hear you.
They can't hear me? No, we
can hear you. We can hear you.
We can also hear it twice. Twice.
Yeah. Hey, I'm Jad, I boom. Rod.
I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab, and today,
oops. Oops. You don't, you don't hear.
You don't hear us.
We have a story about how the echoes of
you can go out into the world and come
back and bite you in all
of this really in the bud.
Hmm. Uh, oh wait, wait. Maybe
we're fine now. Is My echo gone?
Yes. Okay. Okay. We're good. We're good.
[inaudible] and it comes to us from our
producers. Simon Adler. Yeah. Like nick.
Hello? I'm sorry. Okay,
so this is Nick Bilton.
My name is Nick Bilton. I'm a special
correspondent for Vanity Fair and is beat,
you could say is trying to predict the
future of technology to look into the
future.
I'm into this kind of crystal ball
and try to predict what the next five,
10, 15 years would look
like for the media industry.
Do you have a good batting
record? Like did you,
did you call some big well yeah, you know,
phones in our pockets that would be like
super computers that social media would
drive news, not newspapers and so
on and things like that. So yeah,
it's been pretty good. I
reached out to you because I,
I came across this article that
you wrote an article that, uh,
sent shivers down my spine and I'm not
one to typically be given shivers by
articles. So it,
I guess how did you stumble
into all of this and where did,
where does this start for you? So, uh,
I was sitting around with some friends
in my living room and friend of mine
mentioned, Oh, did you see this
thing that Adobe put out recently?
We live in a time when more people than
ever before believe that they can change
the world. And that
conversation led nick to a video,
a video online of the Adobe Max 2016.
There are tons and tons of
people in the audience. Yeah,
he's amazing. And up in front of them,
it looks like this stage
of a apple product launch,
but sort of beach themed. Why
Beach? I have absolutely no idea.
That's a little bit to
your mind. I got, Hey,
there are two hosts that are sitting
in these like lifeguard chairs,
comedian Jordan Peele, Jordan Peele is
in key and Peele, Jordan Peele. Yes.
And then the other host is this woman Kim
Chambers who is a marathon swimmer and
an Adobe employee. And then please
welcome to the stage on walks,
Zay, UGA.
Hello everyone. Young guy glasses.
You guys have been making
wear to staff online.
Great photo chain.
And he says Adobe is known for Photoshop.
We're known for editing
photos and doing that
magical things visually.
Well we'll do the nectar thing today.
Let's do something to no speech pulls
up the screen on a Mac computer.
Wow. I have overtaken today's
piece ball deal where um,
there's mech key talking to peel about
his feeling after getting nominated.
Keegan, Michael Key had been
nominated for an Emmy and a,
he and Jordan Peele were talking about it.
Ah, there's a pretty interesting, uh,
joke here. So let's, uh, let's, uh,
just here yet. Uh, I jumped
out of the bed and, um,
and uh, uh, I kissed my dogs
and my wife in that order.
Not a bad joke. So that's uh,
that's do something here. Okay.
So suppose a Michael K one, two,
send this audio to his life.
In other words,
what if Keegan Michael Key was feeling
like that was a little bit rough on my
wife? That was a little
bit mean. Uh, you know,
maybe he wanted to go and rewrite history
and say that he kissed his wife before
the dog.
Okay. Actually want his wife
to go before the dogs. So,
okay, so what are we doing
easily?
So you clicks a button in the program
automatically generates a transcript of
the audio and projects it up on
the screen behind him. You know,
just text of what Keegan
Michael Key said. Okay,
let me zooming a little
bit and then copy paste.
He just highlights the word wife
and pastes it over in front of dogs.
Okay, let's listen to it. Clicks play.
And uh, uh, I kissed my wife and my dogs.
Woo.
[inaudible]
oh, so he was able to move the,
edit the audio by moving the text around
in a text box. Yes, exactly. Okay.
Well that's kind of
cool. Kind of impressive.
Wait, but then here's more, here's
more. Uh, we can talk to types.
Onfi. That's not here. So, wait, wait,
what? Just hang on. Just hang on.
I have heard that, um,
actually a dot on that day. Oh,
actually kissed our Jordan.
So sorry to recover the
truth. Let's do this.
He goes back into that little word box
though. Let's remove the word my here.
Your secrets out. Just
type the word Jordan.
So he typed it out. J. O. R.
D. A. N. N. Just to be clear,
Keegan Michael Key did not see
Jordan anywhere in this clip.
And here we go. And, uh, uh,
I kissed Jordan and my dogs.
Wait,
he just typed in a word that the guy never
said and it made the guy say the word
he never said as if he
actually said it exactly.
Well you will, which
jumps out of his lifeguard
chair started sort of
stomping around the stage.
You were, you were demon. Oh yeah.
I have a magic and to the lot magic I
cannot show you guys is we calculate small
phrases. So let's say,
okay, what were your mood? He
deletes the words, my dogs.
Any types three times.
Oh Man. Tea Bag. And uh, I
kissed Jordan three times.
Oh,
all right. Wait, you are saying
that Keegan Michael Key never said,
ever said Jordan. Never said
three. Never said times. Never,
never said any of those words. And
somehow just from the typing in of it,
the guy is now saying them and
we're hearing them in his voice.
That's what just happened. Yup. That
is exactly what the demo claims.
It's essentially Photoshop for audio.
Nick built. And again, you could take, uh,
uh,
as little as 20 minutes of someone's voice
type the words and it creates in that
voice, um, that sentence with just 20
minutes of the guy talking. Yes. What,
how, how in heaven do you do this?
Okay. Well, and so we're,
we're here to Doby. Um, what,
what exactly do you do here? Sure.
I'm the product manager for audio.
This is during Gleaves. Um,
I flew out to Seattle and tracked him
down to ask him exactly that question.
So essentially what it does is it does
an analysis of the speech and it creates
a models and it, it basically, uh, and
he explained to me that this program,
which they called Voco by the way, um,
what it does is it takes
20 minutes or actually 40,
if you want the best
results of you talking.
And it figures out all of
the phonetics of your speech.
All of the sounds that you make finds
each little block of sound and speech that
is in the recordings, chops them all up.
And then when you go and type things
in, it will recombine those, um,
into that new word. But what
if it encounters a sound
that I'd never made? Well,
uh, the theory is in 40 minutes of speech,
which is the amount they
recommend you feed in,
you're gonna probably say just about every
sound really in the English language.
So if, if really sort of
like phonetically I go,
I run through the gamut and
in 40 minutes, yes. Wow.
Well in, uh, like what would you,
or what are you hoping people will,
would use a product like Foco for?
Uh, so for the video production tools and
for what audition is used for a lot is
dialogue. Editing.
The whole idea during said is to help
people that work in movies and TV.
A lot of our customers record great
audio on set the actors and the dialogues
and everything. Uh, and
when they come back,
if sometimes there's a
mistake or they make a change,
like the actor on set said shoe,
but what he was pointing out with
obviously a boot. And right now there's,
they do what's called ADR.
They'll bring the actor in,
they'll rerecord some lines and they'll
try and drop that into the video.
But there's a lot of, you're
not using the same microphones,
you're not in the same location.
The actor might be sick that day.
So up his voice sounds
different and things you,
a lot of times you can really hear
that standout. And in productions,
if they don't get it just right or with
Voco you just delete the word shoe type
in boot and boom,
there it is using the same source media
and the same characteristics and have it
just sounds seamless and natural and
[inaudible] it's going to be a sort of,
the hope is that it will make the lives
of professional postproduction editors
easier the world over. That's
our hope right now. Yeah,
but that's not exactly,
well, it's, I mean it's, um,
what Nick Bilton thought when,
um, when he saw this video,
it could be Donald Trump's
voice or Vladimir Putin. Um,
so I saw that and I thought, wow,
if imagine if audio clips start
getting shared around the Internet,
um, as fake news about fake
conversation between, you know,
Vladimir Putin and Paul Manafort about
trying to get Trump into the white house
or something like that right
now. It was like, Whoa, this is,
this is scary stuff.
But we're just getting started in the
words of John Raymond Arnold played by
Samuel L. Jackson in the movie Jurassic
Park in his own voice. Hold on to you.
But things that are
about to get a lot crazy
[inaudible]
so forget voices for a second because now
one, two, three, four, five, one, two,
three, four, five. It's facetime.
All right. We are at the Paul G.
Allen Center at the University
of Washington in Seattle.
So I left Adobe and went across town to
talk to the head of the grail lab euro.
Yeah. Very nice to meet Dr Era
Chem Omakase Schlitz Herman.
I'm a professor in the computer
science department at the University of
Washington and Elsa work at Facebook.
Can I just have you come a little closer?
Okay. Just to back up for a second. When
Nick first saw the VOCO demonstration,
he started to wonder, okay, like how
could this be used down the road?
And my original thesis was, oh,
well maybe what will happen is that you
will be able to create three d actors
just like you did in star wars.
Then join it with the voco stuff to create
a fake Hillary Clinton and you know,
Donald Trump having a conversation or
making out or whatever it is you want to
do. And that led him to investigate
the type of work that era does.
Should I've been using these terms
like facial reenactment and facial
manipulation? Are those the,
are those the right words?
And then what the hell do
these words mean? Yeah. So, um,
I mean it's all,
it's all a way of animating faces
and it started from the movies,
right? The concept is to drive these
remotely controlled bodies called avatars.
I think like the aptly named movie Avatar
or a sergeant. Yes. Going
a little further back.
No sign of intelligent
life anywhere, toy story,
and to make the characters come alive.
What you need is the expressions
of the actors playing them.
This is the movie space. It means that
you will bring a person to his studio.
Then you covered their face with these
sticky sensory marker things and then
they will spend hours, hours,
hours capturing the person's little
dynamics like smiled up in miles teeth,
claws, mas, no teeth had a surprised
disturbance. Like that. Angry, bloated,
yeah, frustrated.
And from that they create a virtual
character capable of emoting all those
expressions. And to make
that character believable,
the animators sometimes have to
model a bone structure and muscles.
And as you can imagine, this
can get very, very expensive.
And so what people like eras
started to wonder was like,
can this be done on a budget?
So she and others in the field started
feeding videos of faces into computers
and trained those computers to break
down the face into a series of points.
I models are about a two 50 by two 50
that is 62,500 points on one human face.
And then once we know that, right,
we can track the planes. Okay.
So once you can track how my face moves
through a video clip by these 250 by 250
points, what can you then do
with that information? Well,
I can apply the points on the face on a
different model of a different person.
Now this is, this is where
things get quite strange, uh,
because instead of being able to map
all of your facial movements onto a
computer generated a virtual
character or person, uh,
with era and others in this
field of facial reenactment have,
have figured out how to do is to map
your facial movements onto a real person,
a, a prerecorded real person.
What, what does that even mean?
How does that work? The, the
best example of this is a,
is this piece of software
that nick showed us a,
this software that I found from these
university students called face to face
sweet present,
a novel realtime facial reenactment method
that works with any commodity Webcam.
There's a video demo of this.
And, um, when you open it up, uh,
this very monotone voice comes in saying,
since our method only uses RGB data
for both the source and target actor,
and you're like, what the heck is
this? And the screen pops up here,
we demonstrate our method in
a live setup on the right,
you've got this heavyset man
goatee, spiked hair on the right,
a source actor is captured with the
standard webcam arching his eyebrows.
He's pursing his lips, he's opening
his mouth widely. The sort of like a,
like if you're making funny faces for
a two year old kind of thing. Yeah.
And then this input drives the animation
of the face and the video shown on the
Monitor to the left.
On the left you've got this Dell computer
screen displaying a CNN clip of George
Bush. This is a real clip of Bush
back from 2013. And his face is,
they're looking right at the camera.
Occupies most of that screen. Yeah.
Significant difference
to previous methods.
What you start to notice is when
the man with the goatee smiles,
George Bush in the CNN clip also smiles.
And when the man raises his eyebrows,
George Bush raises his eyebrows and you
realize this man is controlling George
Bush's face. Wait, so this is a guy in,
in the present controlling
a past George Bush.
A real George Bush from an old video clip.
Yeah. Okay. I pulled up a
video for you here. Okay, cool.
And a little while back when we
were just learning about this,
we happened to have our friend Andrew
[inaudible] who writes for the New Yorker
in the studio.
So that is George Bushes
face. [inaudible] what?
Oh God. Oh God.
That's terrifying. His,
okay. So yeah, I cannot stop
watching George Bush's face. Oh,
they're doing it with Putin now. Holy God.
So I just have a guy just sort of going
[inaudible] and then that's what Putin
is doing. Yeah. Oh, now it's Trump.
You know, I mean, those videos
online had my mouth agape again,
Nick Bilton. This is this, this is a
form of puppetry where your face is the,
is the puppeteer than the only
thing is, is, is that George W.
Bush is the puppet. So I sit
in front of a camera, I smile,
and the business is taken
care of. That's real time.
This isn't like you have to render
some software on your computer.
It's literally you download a clip or
you take a clip from the cable news and
you turn on your Webcam and however long
it takes you to do it and you're done.
It's the same as to shooting a video
on your phone. What is this for? What,
what are the applications that
Jason, um,
I want to be able to help cal develop
telepresence. This is era again.
So I love Pres telepresence.
Yeah. So for example,
so my mom leaves in Israel, um,
and I'm here and I'm, what is
it? Be Cool if I could, um,
have some guy, it's kind
of crazy, but right.
But if I could have some kind of Hologram
of her sitting on my couch here and we
can have a conversation
and going one step further.
One of your colleagues,
a guy by the name of Steve Sights.
I'm a professor at the University of
Washington and I also work part time at
Google.
He told me that they see this technology
as like a building block that could one
day be used to essentially virtually
bring someone back from the dead.
I just think this technology combined
with the virtual reality and other
innovations could help me, you know,
just be there in the room with
Albert Einstein or Carl Sagan.
Know that that's sort of the
motivation. That's what they want to do.
That's the motivation. Talk to
ghosts. Well for them, yes. And uh,
when I was talking to some
folks who work in commercials,
they're developing their own
version of this and the idea is, uh,
that they're gonna make a million
or $1 billion off of this because a,
say you bring, I don't know, uh,
Jennifer Aniston in to film some makeup
commercial and in the makeup commercial
in English, she says, so
come and buy this product.
This is the best sort of whatever product
around right now you've got China,
which is a booming market.
You may be want to market things to
China and really like to be able to use
Jennifer Anniston. Problem is Jennifer
Annison doesn't speak Mandarin,
so either you use the same audio clip
and you have someone come in and speak
Mandarin over her and
the lips don't line up.
Or You have to hire a mandarin speaking
a actor to come in and do the part of
Jennifer Anniston with this technology.
All you have to do is
record Jennifer Aniston.
Once you can hire a mandarin speaker
and the mandarin speakers voice will be
coming out of Jennifer Aniston's mouth
is if she had said it in front of the
camera, her lips would be moving as if
she were a perfect mandarin speaker.
Exactly, exactly. Wow. I think
that part of it is actually,
that's amazing. Yeah. Oh my God.
I'm amazed and completely frightened
by what you're telling me.
And that's the whole point of what
nick was writing about that, uh,
that gave me shivers that someday if
you join the video manipulation with the
Voco voice manipulation,
you're, you're the,
the ultimate puppeteer. You can create
anyone talking about anything that you
want in their own voice and having any
kind of emotion around it.
And you'd have it right there
for everyone to see in video.
And all you need to do is take that
and put it on Twitter or Facebook.
And if it's shocking enough, I
minutes later it's everywhere.
Like the timing of you guys making this
thing and then this explosion of fake
news like, Huh? How do
you guys think about,
about how it could be used for, for
nefarious purposes? Uh,
yeah, it's a good question.
Um, again, you're a [inaudible] I feel
like when every technology is developed,
then there, there is this danger of
uh, these are technology. You, um,
you can create fake videos and so on
or I don't want to call it fake videos,
but I'd like to create video from audio.
Right. But they are fake videos. Yeah.
Yeah. But the way that I
think about it is that like,
scientists are doing their job in science,
like inventing the
technology and sign it off.
And then we all need to like think
about the next steps. Obviously. I mean,
people should work on that. Um,
and the answer is not clear.
Maybe it's education. Maybe it's, um,
every video should come up with
some code now that this is,
this is like authentic video or authentic
attacks and you don't believe anything
else. I mean, yeah, but like, it maybe
it was the timing more than anything,
but I saw this video and it
really felt like, oh my God,
like America can't handle this right now.
Like we're in a moment where w we're,
we're truth seems to be
sort of a, an open desk.
What is true is has become
an open discussion and this
seems to be adding fuel
on the fire of sort of, uh,
competing narratives in a way that I find
troubling. And I'm just
curious that you don't,
yeah.
Um, a thing that
I think that people, if people
know the touch technology exists,
then they will be more skeptical.
My guess, I don't know.
But if people know that fake news exists,
if they know that fake text exists,
fake videos exist, fake photos exist,
then everyone is more skeptical
than what they read them see.
But like [inaudible] a
man in North Carolina,
I think he was from North Carolina,
believed from a fake print article that
Hillary Clinton was running a sex ring
out of a pizza parlor in
DC, which is like insane.
This man believed it and
showed up with a gun.
And if people are at a moment where
they are willing to believe stories as
ludicrous, is that like,
I don't expect them to wonder
if this video is real or not.
Yeah.
Um, so whether you asking,
I'm asking, well, I'm asking do you, are
you afraid of the power of [inaudible]
and if not, why?
Just I'm just giving my, I don't know it
just, Ah, I'm answering your questions,
but I'm a technologist. I'm a
computer scientist, so I'm not really,
because I know how to read and I know
that because I know that this technology
is reversible. I mean,
nobody, well, there is not,
not worried too much
[inaudible]
have you seen these videos? Otherwise I
can text it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I have.
And as we were feeling
worried and more than that,
surprised that the folks making
these technologies weren't.
We decided to do a third gut check.
See if we were totally off base and get
in touch with one of the guys who's on
the front lines of this.
Can you describe what was going through
your head when you were watching Bush's
face? I can tell you exactly what
I was thinking. I was thinking,
how are we going to develop a
forensic technique to detect this?
This is honey for reed.
I am a professor of computer
science at Dartmouth College.
He's sort of like a Sherlock
Holmes of digital misdeeds,
which means that spends a lot of time
sitting around looking at pictures and
videos, trying to understand
where has this come from?
Has it been manipulated
and should we trust it?
He's done work for all sorts
of organizations. The AP,
The Times Reuters who want to know
if say a picture is fake or not,
they often will ask me, you have to leave.
When this just happened at two yesterday,
images came out of North Korea and every
time images come out of these regimes
where there was a history
of photo manipulation,
there are real concerns about this.
So I was asked to determine if they'd
been manipulated in some way and if so,
how had they been manipulated and what,
how, how the heck would you do that?
Wow. Every time you manipulate data
you're going to leave something
behind. Um, so, so let's say you
do some funny business to a photo,
you might create some noticeable
distortion in the picture itself,
but you also might distort the data.
And we're in the business of basically
finding those distortions in the data.
For example, imagine he gets sent a
photo, it's probably a Jpeg, jpeg,
which now is 99% of the image formats
that we see out there is what is called
the lossy compression scheme.
Just a fancy way to say that when a
photo is taken and stored as a Jpeg,
the camera, you know, just to save space
throws a little bit of the data away.
So for example,
if I went out to the Dartmouth green
right now took a picture of the grass,
the camera isn't going to store all those
millions of little variations of green
hidden in the grass because
that would be just a huge file.
It's going to save space by
throwing some of those greens away.
You just don't notice if it changes like
a lot or a little bit less than that.
It just grass as far as you can
tell. Now, here's how these trick.
Every camera has a subtly different
Palette of Greens that's going to keep and
greens that's going to throw away.
This varies tremendously
from device to device.
An iPhone compresses the image much more
so less Greens in a high end icon or a
high on cannon, which would keep
more of the variations of green.
Now if you hold these two
pictures side by side,
you might not be able to tell
the difference, but honey says,
when you look at the underlying pixels,
there are different recognizable patterns.
You take an image off of your iPhone.
I should be able to go into that jpeg
and look at the packaging and say, ah,
yes, this should have
come out of an iPhone.
But if that image is uploaded to Facebook
and then re downloaded or put into
Photoshop and received, it will not look
like jpeg consistent with an iPhone.
So basically he can see it, the
level of the pixels or data,
whether the picture has been messed with
in any way. Huh. And this is of course,
just one of many different ways that
honey can spot a fake. Yeah. Let me ask,
if you could go up against the
top 100 best counterfeiters,
do you think you'd catch
them 10% of the time,
50% of the time just to have
kids? What's your sense? Um,
I would say we could probably
catch 75% of the fakes,
but I would say that would take a long
time to do. This is not an easy task.
And so, you know, the,
the pace at which the media moves does
not lend itself to careful forensic
analysis of images. Um, I'm always amazed
that, you know, you get these emails,
you're like, all right, you got 20
minutes and um, you would need, you know,
half a day, a day per image, still a
very manual in a very human process.
It's so are,
is this video editing and this audio
editing that's coming down the pipeline
here? Yeah, I guess, should
I be, should I be terrified?
Um, yes, you should. Um, oh no.
Did you, you really mean that?
Yeah, I think it's,
I think it's going to raise the fake
news thing to a whole new level.
I did see some artifacts, by the way
in the videos, they are not perfect,
but that's neither here nor there
because the ability of technology to
manipulate and alter reality is
growing at a breakneck speed. Um,
and the ability to disseminate that
information is phenomenal. So I,
I can't stop that by the way,
because at the end of the day,
it's always going to be easier to create
a fake than to detect a fake. Hmm.
[inaudible]
right. Thank you very
much. We're going to,
Chad himself just handed
me a cup of water,
which shows none of you have gotten too
big for your britches and that could be
a serious problem.
I would like to have seen Peter
Jennings do that ever for this guy.
My name is John Klein, Co founder
and CEO of tap media. Before that,
president of CNN,
u s before that I was
executive vice president of
CBS News where I was executive
in charge of 60 minutes,
48 hours and a bunch of other things
and he's had to react to some serious
evolutions in the media industry. Uh,
he was manning the helm as social
media exploded as smartphones became
ubiquitous.
And consequently he had to deal with
figuring out how and if to trust thousands
of hours of video taken on these
smart phones and sended by viewers,
what to broadcast and what not.
And so we wanted to know how someone
in his position would think about these
fake videos.
So we sent him all of the different
demos and videos we'd come across just to
see what he thought.
First thought was that this is the kind
of thing that a James Bond villain would
put to use or a the joker in Batman
or an eighth grade girl who right.
Wants to be most popular. Exactly.
Yeah. You know, I mean, this is,
there's so many ways to
abuse this blows your mind.
I mean, it,
it goes to the very core of
communication of any sort,
whether it's television
or radio or interpersonal.
Um, it is what I'm seeing. True
is what I'm hearing real, uh,
in, in your, over the
course of your career,
you've seen multiple
technological developments
that have impacted the media in
rather profound ways. Where is
your terror level right now,
or your fear level caused by this
relative to all of the other sorts of
advancements that have occurred over,
over your career? It's terrifying.
And it,
it hurdles us even faster toward that
point where no one believes anything.
How do you have a democracy in a country
where people can't trust anything that
they see or read anymore? What,
what we saw happen with the fake news
during the election cycle was that, um,
all the, the, it doesn't, it didn't
even need to matter if anyone, you know,
would rebuff it afterwards.
This is nick built. And again,
it would reach millions and
millions of in me or seconds and,
and you, and that was it.
You'd done it had done its job.
And I think that with this audio
stuff, uh, and the video stuff,
that's gonna that's going to come down,
uh, uh, on online in the next few years.
Um, it's gonna do the same thing, but,
but no one's gonna know
what's real and what's not.
I moved on her actually, you
know, she was down in Palm Beach.
I moved on her NFL.
And what's more, Nick says,
if you think about the video that
came out of Donald Trump from access,
Hollywood
automatically attracted to
beautiful. I just started,
the thing that was really
interesting about that video
when you were started, they let
you do it. You can do anything,
whatever you want, grab him by the,
you don't actually see Donald Trump until
the very last second when he gets off
the bus. How were you high? You
only hear him make me a soapstone.
I'm a little hugged with Donnelley and
so if that technology existed today,
I can guarantee you that Donald Trump
would have responded by saying, oh,
it's fake. It's fake news.
Fake audio. You can't see me.
I didn't say that and it would just
be, this video is word against his
[inaudible].
Actually, that's kind of like for me,
that's sort of the real problem here.
Like you create this,
this possibility for like
plausible deniability.
That's so broad. You know what
I mean? It's like, you know,
it's like the tobacco industry in the
sixties and seventies I was just reading
this great article by a,
the writer Tim Harford about this in
the sixties and seventies the tobacco
industry led this very calculated effort
to sort of push back against cancer
science by just injecting
a little bit of doubt here.
A little bit of doubt there, right there
on the other hand. On the other hand,
this and on the other hand that,
and the idea was to create just enough
wiggle room that nothing happens.
They do that with climate
change too. Exactly. Yeah.
And it's that little bit of
doubt that creates paralysis.
And is that what's going to happen that
like there's going to be paralysis now
writ large because now we're talking
about the very things we see,
the very things we hear
[inaudible]
but wait,
but we don't you think that before we
get completely carried away with the
threat of this technology
because, you know,
maybe we should just find out
literally where we are now. Yeah.
We should give it a spin.
Yeah. So at this moment,
do you think making one of these
eclipses is, is possible? Okay.
I think it's entirely possible. Um, it
just, I would be careful what it is.
[inaudible]
after the break, things get
fake.
[inaudible]
hi everyone. It's Angela
calling from Dallas, Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
Thanks Radiolab.
Jad Robert Radiolab. So we're back.
We're going to now fake something.
We're going to build our own video
from scratch. Fake words, fake faces,
because we want to know like in use,
how dangerous are these technologies
really? Can they make a convincing fake?
Are they as easy as advertised?
So we will find out by
giving the assignment as
always to our long suffering.
Simon Adler. So while I was in
Seattle talking to during Gleaves,
I not so subtly hinted that
I would really like to, uh,
to give vocal a world. Let's say
I had my hands on it somehow.
What can I do with it?
Well, right now, nothing,
because we haven't shared
it with them. At first,
I just thought he didn't want me
to be able to play around with it.
But then I realized that a, and I don't
even have a personal copy for myself,
but yet I, so it's not even
on the premises here. No,
it's still very much
contained to research.
Oh, but
hi. Hi there. Hey Matt. I,
yeah, yeah, here. Great.
Eventually I got in touch with
this guy. So I'm Dr Matthew Elites.
I'm the Chief Science Officer
at Sarah Proc Limited,
which is a vocal sentences research
company based in Edinburgh. Yeah,
I called you up because I was hoping that
you could help me to make a video clip
that has, I don't know,
like George Bush or Barack Obama saying
things that they have never sent.
Yep. That sounds great. That's it. It was
just game. Yeah, no. See the thing is,
what his company does is
not quite the same as Voco.
What they do is like for a client,
they'll create a voice that you can
then just type in words or sentences and
make that voice say whatever
you want it to say. I feel sad.
That's an interesting idea. They've, uh,
created voices with a variety of accents.
Great for you said last summer
in a variety of languages.
[inaudible]
and in their spare time when they're not
making voices for clients [inaudible]
governor knowledge. What's negative?
I think they're building celebrity voices
future and it just so happens they've
got a Barack Obama and
a George Bush Bot. Yeah.
How did you create a
George Bush robot? Well,
a great thing about George Bush is that
he was president of the United States
for some time. The morning,
good morning, good morning,
which means he had to give the weekly
presidential address. We can go today.
I received a great honor and the
other great thing about the addresses,
it's completely copyright free,
so we were allowed to do anything we
liked with that audio for the people of
America, maybe things that they haven't
envisaged that we going to do with it.
Real quick digression here just
because it's absolutely fascinating.
It looks like we're actually about to
enter this really sticky gray area when it
comes to ownership. For
example, in Rodeo book,
If you record an audio book and you've
signed over the rights to those audio
files to the publisher, the publisher
has the copyright. You, you,
you don't own it. You do not own your
own voice. Is that really true? Yeah.
Anyway, back to Bush,
so I took all those weekly
addresses about six hours worth,
which is a lot more tape
than Volvo's 20 minutes,
but what he did with it
is pretty similar, right?
You Fed them into this machine learning
algorithm along with their transcripts.
And then with the program, we'll do it.
We'll take the text and it will analyze
it in terms of the linguistics that will
say, this is the word,
social security, social,
what social is made out of
the sound, sir. Oh right.
And so we'll cut those sounds out
into lots of little tiny pieces.
And it did that for all of the words
in all of these addresses
around 80,000 in total.
Put them all in this database with tons
of info about what sound came before it
after, et cetera. And once that database
is built, all that's left to do,
I type in some text and then I push,
go and try and find a
set of little sounds,
which will join together really nicely.
And then I push play in the
see how well they came out.
So what we did was we found an
old video of former presidents,
George Bush and Barack Obama together,
they're shaking hands,
making generic statements.
The exact clip isn't important,
but we wondered could we turn that
clip from a boring meet and greet to a
scenario where Bush is
telling Obama a joke.
So we convinced a comedy
writer Rachel Axler,
who works for the show veep to write as
few jokes and then sent it off to Matt
and this is what the computer spat out
and well it goes to something like
knock knock. Who's there? Oval. Oval.
Oval. I think it's something
about the Oval Office. Probably.
That was a a very good joke. Mr
President, my wife Laurie tells it better.
What the hell is that? Wait,
what was it that was terrible?
That was like, was it,
I don't even get, Hey,
I don't understand that joke at all.
And that's literally what
the computer's flat out.
That is what the computer
spit out. And truth be told,
I don't think it's anywhere it, it did.
It is not worthy of the negative
response that you are getting. Terrible.
Terrible. Let me show you another one.
So happy to be joining forces with
this good man to put cortisone in your
drinking water.
This all gets to help protect people's
teeth so they don't get fillings.
Isn't that fluoride? Oh shoot.
I think I signed the wrong bill.
That's good. That's a legitimate
no, that the robots are terrible.
Joke is funny. Yeah. I liked the joke,
but the robot just massacred that joke,
which is in itself kind of a joke. Well,
I do think it, yeah, let me get into,
well,
I think you two are far more than you
should be and you're far more critical
than the average listener. However,
Matt is so wrong about it. But anyway.
Anyhow, Matt did tell me that, uh,
conversations I getting people to see the,
to talk back and forth to each other
are still really difficult for a
synthesizer to do.
But you know, conversational stuff
is always difficult and in fact,
we're going to see, it's going to
be a long time before we get really,
really easy conversational synthesis.
There's all sorts of barriers to that.
There's a human quality, uh, to a,
to a conversation that, uh, that,
that the synthesizers can't quite capture
yet. But he also told us that, um,
you know, if we add, once we add the
video or if we add a video to this, uh,
it will smooth out a lot
of, a lot of the problems
when you have the faces as well speaking.
People are not focusing in the audio and
you can't hear that the arrows in the
same way.
So
hello?
Hey, is this Kyle? Oh yeah, great,
great. I found these two Grad students.
My name is [inaudible]. I
am Tyler Shefsky from uh,
the University of southern California USC.
They also do a lot of facial reenactment
research and agreed to help us. But,
uh, making these visuals also turned
out to be way harder than we thought.
It turned out the clip we chose
posed some serious challenges. Uh,
there were too many side
shots of Obama's face. Uh,
the lighting was all wrong and, uh,
eventually I got an email one late Sunday
night saying, uh, it's not gonna work.
Okay. So now I think I can draw a line
here and I can point out that this,
that we maybe got overexcited
about this technology.
It is not yet ready for true deceit.
You have been fumbling and
fumbling and fumbling here.
I have with them fumbling. I am not. Okay.
I find it interesting psychologically
that Simon feels like it's a personal
failure. I don't like to fail.
You should. This is failure,
so, okay.
Just just uh, just on Simon's behalf,
on the behalf of actually trying to
answer the question, we felt like, okay,
maybe, maybe we should
try this one last time.
Let's find a simpler Obama video and
with the audio rather than like whole
phrases. Let's just do a couple of word
replacements here or there. By the way,
the only reason we're using Obama
is that he seems to be the cow.
All of these technologies
are built around it.
In case we chose the video of Obama's
last weekly address and we chose the audio
from a talk he'd given in
Chicago after he left off.
What's been known.
I want to know in this speech he sort of
talks about what he's going to do next,
how he's still going to keep fighting
for what he believes is right,
filled with idealism and absolutely
certain that somehow I was going to change
the world. But we thought,
what if in an alternate reality
he didn't want to keep fighting.
What if he could at that moment see the
divisions ahead and he was just like,
that's too much. I give up now.
Truth is we didn't think too hard about
this cause we didn't have much time.
We just whipped it together.
Did a script based on words.
Obama used with a few changes,
send it off to the guys at USC.
All right. And I videotaped myself,
uh, seeing this new script so that, uh,
we can use that video of my face to pop
a ties, the former president. And uh,
when, when we got the final video back,
I have to say it was,
I was expecting it to be horrible
and where did it have a good laugh?
But I it went from like Laffy Kalitta to,
oh wait, this is creepy.
Well, yeah, no, I, I was suddenly,
uh, I had been gang busters.
We got to release this thing, uh,
and not tell anybody and try to fake
out the entire world. Uh, but when,
when I saw it, there was,
uh, a reluctancy. You mean
you went, oh no, I went,
Oh God, yeah, yeah. I
thought, oh, this, this,
and you know, my personal
thought was like,
it was convincing enough that I got
genuinely spooked. But you know,
just in fairness,
we shouldn't sit around talking
about something people can't see.
Go to future of fake news.com and check
it out for yourself. It's all one word,
future of fake news.com and
it'll pop right up. You can see,
tell us what you think. You can see
how Simon made the video. Check it out.
Anyhow, the whole process got
us all thinking like, oh wow.
Well if we bunch of idiots can do this,
uh, for no money very, very quickly,
what will this mean to like a newsroom?
For example, just to start there.
Uh, we're at the level now with,
with this kind of thing where
we need technologists to,
to verify or knocked down. And
again, news executive, John Klein,
I don't think journalists, English majors
are, are, are going to be the ones to,
to solve this. You know, you, you may
have been editor of your school paper,
but this is beyond your, your capability.
But if you're good at collaborating
with engineers and scientists,
uh, you know, you, you'll,
you'll have a good chance of working
together to you to figure it out.
So we need,
we need technical expertise
more than we ever have.
Okay. Can I ask you in
your heart, this isn't,
and they let me compare your heart to
my heart for a second. In my heart,
I want somebody to tell the researchers
he has, sorry, you can't do that.
Sorry. You know, I know.
It's really cool. I know you,
I know you probably are really
proud of that algorithm, but um,
some men in black are going to walk in
right now and they're gonna take your
computers away and, and
you, you just can't, sorry.
Society is going to overrule
you right now. Did you,
is there a part of you
that just dictatorial,
he wants to just like
squash this [inaudible]
well sure. But wouldn't you
still have the, what are they,
the FSB and Moscow or the CIA utilizing
this and developing it anyway,
weaponizing it so to speak.
Probably and I think that the top
down model could never contain that.
John says ultimately what's happening
is probably going to be bigger than any
one organization or any
one newsroom can solve.
He said it'll probably end up coming down
to the 14 and 15 year olds of tomorrow
who will grow up using this
technology, making fake videos,
being the victims of fake videos and
that maybe in the maze of them having to
parse truth from fiction
in such a personal way.
Some kind of code will develop.
I'm an optimist by nature. I do.
I look at this and I say, well,
somebody's going to figure it out.
What worries me is the larger context
within this state within which this takes
place. Uh, this is all occurring
within a context of massive news,
illiteracy and the,
the consumers seem to be just throwing
their hands up and tiring of trying to
even figure it out. And
so just the, the, the,
the work involved in getting to the
bottom of the truth is unappealing to a
growing percentage of the audience.
And I'm not sure where Gen z the
teenagers of today come out on this.
Let's hope that they are
more willing to do the work.
Maybe out of self interest, maybe so
that they're not dissed by, you know,
the girl in social studies. But that's
our best hope for overcoming it.
Okay.
Because everybody else
seems to be sick of trying
[inaudible]
uh Huh.
Reporters, Simon Adler. This piece
was produced by Simon and Amy McCune.
[inaudible]
very special thanks to Kyle o Shefsky
and the entire team at USC Institute for
Creative Technology for all their work,
manipulating that video
of President Obama.
And thanks to Matthew Aylett for Cindy,
the sizing. So, so many words for us.
Rachel Axler for writing us the
jokes that we tried to use. Uh,
so from power for billing, it's an
amazing website, Angus Neil, Amy parle,
everybody in the w NYC
newsroom for advising us and
giving us reaction shots to
the face to face video and to David
Carroll for putting us in touch with Nick
Bilton in the first place.
And to Nick Dalton for inspiring
this whole story with his article,
he's got a new one,
a book actually American kingpin about
the founder of a black market website
called the Silk Road and to superstar
in switching the coin computer scientist
who works in eras lab, who helped us
understand what the heck was going on.
And finally you can see the video that
we created as well as a bunch of other
kind of a crazy that we mentioned
throughout this episode.
It's at future of fake
news.com. All one word,
future of fake news.com.
And uh, with that,
my real cohosts and I will
bet you a Jew. I'm jet Booman.
I'm rob crow, which who we really are.
I'm glad we could finally be
honest about that all these years.